ehi è da tanto tempo che volevo dirtelo
io ti amo ti penso sempre di sonno la
notte
insomma spero che tu provi le stesse
cose per me te l'ho detto fin al mese ma
[Musica]
ehi ma che ci fai qui io abito proprio
qua se vuoi una di queste sere ci
facciamo un aperitivo dai allora presto
ciao ciao ciao come stai
e come fa tua sorella
non è noto sorella ed è allora saluto
salutami
[Musica]
cosa ti scrivo cosa posso scriverli che
lo colpisca ei frate come butta ci
vediamo o dividere inviato veramente
ultima cosa su impazzita ai frati come
butta ci vediamo molta sottono proprio
mio sì ma sei pazzo ma potete avvisarmi
guarda mi coglie impreparata smo mezza
nuda dove vieni dentro dieci minuti sono
pronte aspettami qui beh in realtà sarei
a dieta ma visto che sei affamato potrei
prepararti un arrosto con patate e una
parmigiana
dammi dieci minuti ed è tutto pronto non
troviamo detto che ho lavorato anche
come scelta in un ristorante stellato ha
avuo vuoi mangiare
sì io non sono bravissimo a cucinare
però vedo se ho qualcosa da offrire
andiamo andiamo sotto c'è un posto molto
buono se vuoi agli hamburger sì ciao
katia allora ho un appuntamento super
importante per cui volevo prenotare una
certa completa piega manicure pedicure e
un massaggio rilassante
ok con calma finalmente è esco con crash
da dove possiamo iniziare
oddio io n'esco sono troppo brutto come
facciamo di capelli o c'è un rasoio
oddio appunto da fare schifo non farmi
la doccia 20 minuti non vuoi che ti
racconti qualcosa di me
io l'ho scoperto dove iniziare sono
diplomata col massimo dei voti e ho
preso tre lauree omen turisti ad oxford
e ho vissuto in america o in fatto
volontariato per una dinamica e ho anche
ricevuto l'oscar qualche anno fa
vuoi qualcosa di me mi piace fare
shopping ascoltare la musica è poi stata
data al matrimonio cucina ed è stato
divertente giocare sarò briaca terrestre
e ho vomitato addosso mia nonna
niente fai una foto aspetta che mette in
posa robert elefanti fatto cosa stai
facendo non ho una foto mezzo nella
questo diritto non sono renda per favore
non o dai veramente no dai non è andata
troppo bene te lo giuro
lui poi super carino certo c'era intesa
hai capito quello che intendo
no veramente adesso vediamo magari
descrive magari no aspetta un attimo no
vabbè non ci credo giostre fatica mi ha
appena scritto un messaggio mi ha
scritto non vedo l'ora di rivederti
spesso male ma è fatta silenzio stampa
non mi ha neanche scritto ciao un like
me mi sembrava che il nostro
appuntamento così andato bene ma forse
sono per me eccoci arrivati alla fine
del video spero tantissimo che vi sia
piaciuto spiaciuto mi raccomando
mettete un bel haj lasciate un commento
qui sotto facendoli sapere in quali
queste situazioni di si è ritrovato di
tv vi ricordo inoltre di seguirmi su
tutti gli altri social in particolare di
instagram man tt top e facebook vi mando
un bacione e ci vediamo al prossimo
video comodo
ciao
[Musica]